>> Bill: YOU MIGHT KNOW THIS BY
NOW.
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID TO
HAVE SCALED BACK THE GUEST LIST
FOR HIS 60th BIRTHDAY BASH BUT
MAN, WAS THAT TENT BIG.
THE PARTY DID GO ON, HUNDREDS
OF GUESTS IN ATTENDANCE.
FORMER PRESIDENT CAN BE SEEN IN
PICTURES HITTING THE DANCE
FLOOR WITHOUT A MASK.
HE DANCED ALL NIGHT AND HAD A
GREAT TIME.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
HELLO JOE CONCHA.
HERE IS THE COVERAGE BY
NETWORK, ARE YOU READY?
MSNBC, 2 MINUTES 45 SECONDS.
FOX NEWS CHANNEL 17 MINUTES 35
SECONDS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SENSE OF THIS?
>> OH, WELL, IT SEEMS THAT THIS
IS BEING IGNORED FOR SOME
REASON.
WONDER WHY THAT IS?
I THINK THE TENT WILL HOST THE
SUPER BOWL IN 2025.
THAT IS BIG.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AS FOR OUR MEDIA NO MENTION OF
OBAMA FEST ANYWHERE IN THE
SUNDAY TALK SHOWS EITHER.
I WATCH CHUCK TODD ON "MEET THE
PRESS" AND HE BROACHED THE
STURGIS BIKER RALLY WITH DR.
FAUCI.
FAUCI WENT OFF ON THE BIKER
RALLY BUT DIDN'T BRING UP THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S MASKLESS
MEGA PARTY.
AN INCREASING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
MAY THINK -- OUR LEADERS ARE
NOT LEADING BY EXAMPLE WHETHER
IT'S THE FORMER PRESIDENT
OBAMA, WHETHER IT'S NEWSOM,
PELOSI, LIGHTFOOT, BOWSER,
COUNTLESS OTHERS ALL CAUGHT
BREAKING THEIR OWN RULES.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY KNOW MOST OF THE MEDIA
WILL PROVIDE COVER INSTEAD OF
COVERAGE.
>> Bill: A COUPLE OF THINGS
HERE.
LABOR DAY WEEKEND A YEAR AGO
THE PRESIDENT -- FORMER
PRESIDENT TWEETED IT MIGHT BE
LABOR DAY WEEKEND.
WE'RE STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF
PANDEMIC.
WEAR A MASK AND FOLLOW THE
EXPERTS AND IT WILL SAVE LIVES.
THAT WAS BEFORE THE VACCINE.
A LOT OF THINGS CHANGED BACK
THEN.
THERE WAS A SEGMENT WITH A "NEW
YORK TIMES" REPORTER ON CNN.
>> GOING TO BE SAFE.
THIS IS A SOPHISTICATED,
VACCINATED CROWD AND JUST ON
OPTICS, NOT SAFETY.
>> THIS IS A SOPHISTICATED
VACCINATED CROWD AND IT IS JUST
ABOUT OPTICS.
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER
JUSTIFYING THE MASKLESS
BIRTHDAY BASH BECAUSE HE ONLY
INVITED A SOPHISTICATED
VACCINATED CROWD IS ABOUT AS
EMBLEMATIC OF LIBERAL DISCOURSE
AS IT GETS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE CONCERNS
WITH VACCINATED PEOPLE
SPREADING DEALT TAKE TO THE
UNVACCINATED.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER SAID SHE WAS SIMPLY
SHARING THE SENTIMENT OF ONE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD RESIDENT WHO
SAID THE WHOLE THING WAS
OVERBLOWN ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION I WOULD HAVE SPOKEN
TO DOCTORS ON THE ISLAND OR THE
CDC.
BY PRESENTING THIS ARGUMENT THE
GUEST LIST IS A SOPHISTICATED
CROWD SEEMS TO IMPLY THE SMART
AND RESPONSIBLE WERE GOING TO
BE SMART AND RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH
TO TAKE THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
AVOID CONTRACTING THE VIRUS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PHOTOS THE
SMART AND SOPHISTICATED
FLAUNTED ANY CONCEPT OF
MASKING, SOCIAL DISTANCING
INDOORS.
JUST BECAUSE THE TENT WAS
OUTSIDE, IT WAS AN INDOOR EVENT.
DUKES COUNTY WHERE MARTHA'S
VINEYARD LOCATED A HIGH
TRANSMISSION AREA AND REQUIRES
MASKS.
THE PRESIDENT AND OBAMA AND
MOST OF HIS GUESTS IGNORED THAT
WHILE DANCING INSIDE.
IF THAT PARTY WAS SO SAFE IF
THE CRITICISM SO OVERBLOWN WHY
DID THE DEEJAY AT THE PARTY,
WHY WAS HE ORDERED TO DELETE
THEM?
MAY LOOK LIKE THEY'RE HIDING
SOMETHING.
WORLDS FOR THEE, NOT ME.
>> Bill: I SAID WHAT DID THEY
SCALE BACK?
I GUESS SHE SAID NANCY PELOSI
DIDN'T GO OR --
>> Dana: DAVID AXELROD.
>> Bill: ANYWAY, I MEAN GET
YOUR SUPER BOWL TICKETS FOR